a former NFL player is joining thousands
of people suing the company behind
roundup a popular weed killer with a
chemical linked to cancer in a lawsuit
made public yesterday 54 year old
Merrill Hodge says he developed
non-hodgkins lymphoma as a direct result
of being exposed to the herbicide the
company behind roundup says its product
does not cost cancer meg Oliver spoke to
Hodge and is across the river from
Cincinnati in Newport Kentucky meg good
morning good morning a series of brain
injuries forced Hodge to retire from
football in 1994 but he says he's always
been extremely health conscious avoiding
drugs and alcohol that's why for him his
cancer diagnosis he says was especially
shocking as a running back for the
Pittsburgh Steelers for seven years
Merrill Hodge is used to taking on tough
opponents on the gridiron but he says
his biggest challenge was beating cancer
which involved intense chemotherapy can
feel it really literally scream through
your veins hit every part of your body
the burns the hair loss the fatigue of
all Hodge was diagnosed with
non-hodgkins lymphoma back in 2003 and
was declared cancer-free five years
later but he says he only recently
realized his diagnosis could be related
to exposure to the weed killer roundup
which he first used in the late 70s
while working on an Idaho ranch so did
it get on your skin did it get on your
clothes I mean what was it like well
there's nothing using roundup forever
but I didn't have I didn't wear gloves
weren't told wear gloves or mask Hodge
is now suing Monsanto which is owned by
Bayer claiming roundup caused him
life-threatening cancer permanent
injuries physical pain and mental
anguish how do you know it's roundup
that caused your cancer well the only
thing I can tell you is talking to
doctors that's the first thing what they
tell you they're like it were you ever
around a pesticide or stuff what
chemicals like roundup I'm like shared
with my farmer story Joseph Osborn the
sludges attorney this will be a jury
trial we will see seeking recovery for
mr. Hodge and how much would you
estimate that would
it could be in the millions of dollars
the lawsuit claims roundup is dangerous
to human health and unfit to be marketed
and sold in 2015 the International
Agency for research on cancer classified
roundups active ingredient glyphosate as
a probable cause of cancer what's it
like for you when you go into your local
hardware store and you see roundup on
the shelves how can it be there and
still exposed to people without them
knowing it Hodge is one of more than
18,000 plaintiffs who allege exposure to
glyphosate caused them cancer or other
injuries Bayer has lost three court
cases with damages totaling more than
190 million dollars in a statement to
CBS News Bayer says we have great
sympathy for any individual with cancer
but the extensive body of science on
glyphosate based herbicides over four
decades supports the conclusion that
roundup does not cause non-hodgkins
lymphoma the Environmental Protection
Agency says that chemical pose no risks
of concern for people exposed to it even
though Hodge is now cancer-free he says
this lawsuit is about more than just him
I am about how would make things better
for our kids and if I know that
something's being done wrong that is
absolutely harmful to our kids and we
can change it that I'm gonna try to
change it
Hodge still lives in fear his cancer
could return and he could face delayed
side effects from years of treatment
anthony meg another big battle for bayer
thank you very much